(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- All right, all right.
Everyday I like to find
something awesome on social media
that you may have overlooked,
I don't want you to miss out.
You're welcome.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
There's nothing like that joy of knowing
you've got a baby on the way.
There's also nothing quite like the agony
of morning sickness, it sucks.
But check out how one two-year-old
tried to comfort her mama
when a wave of nausea hit.
- It's okay.
I love, Mom.
- I love you too.
- I love you.
It's okay.
It's okay, Mom.
- Thanks, sweetie.
- It's okay.
- [Audience] Aww.
- I mean...
(audience applauding)
That video is tricky,
it makes you wanna have more kids,
and you shouldn't always do that.
But we have little Rosie on the line now,
along with her mama, Katherine,
watching on St. Louis FOX2,
what's up y'all?
- Hi Kelly.
- Hi.
Oh my gosh, you're adorable.
So, Katherine, did you get sick a lot,
the morning sickness?
I did.
- I did, I got so sick.
Not so much with Rosie,
but the second pregnancy was just brutal,
and I was sick the whole nine months,
which is great.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- Rosie got used to me...
(Katherine laughs)
She got used to me running
to the bathroom quite often.
- Yeah, it's miserable.
So, Rosie, what's your favorite
part of being a sister?
(audience laughing)
- She likes giving him hugs
and kisses,
and helping me put him to bed at night,
which sometimes that's more
distracting than helpful,
but it's been sweet.
- How far apart are they?
Mine are 22 months apart,
so my eldest has been momming
the youngest for a minute.
- They're almost, just
shy of three years apart.
- [Kelly] Oh, awesome.
- It's a good age where she can help,
and kind of understand what's going on,
but then they'll also be
able to grow up together,
which I'm really excited to watch them
kind of create that bond.
- Yeah.
I love that I have an older girl,
and the younger is a boy,
I think that's just really sweet,
it's nice to watch.
But you do have to be like
"You're not the mom, calm down."
(indistinct)
Well, Rosie, thank you so much
for being so sweet,
and helping your mama when
she wasn't feeling well.
Katherine, you're doing such a great job,
beautiful kiddo.
Thank you so much for sharing this,
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience cheering and applauding)
All right, well that's not all, Rosie.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion,
the go to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate your growing family,
so they're gonna give you $1,000.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Wow, thank you so much.
- Oh my gosh, your eyes are so beautiful.
Aww, now I want another baby,
this is not good.
(audience laughing)
Thank you guys so much,
have a wonderful evening.
And thank you so much to
all our guests this hour,
Daniel Radcliffe, Lindsay Mendez,
Jonathan Groff, Alix Earle,
Terry, Jen and Joy,
and (indistinct).
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not try and change it.
(upbeat music)